und ich begrüße bei mir den fdp
abgeordneten im bundestag wieland
schinnenburg ich grüße sie sie sind
gewählter abgeordneter sie sind überdies
auch noch gesundheitsexperte der fdp und
trotzdem haben sie alle gemeinsam im
bundestag da weniger zu melden gerade
als zum beispiel das
paul-ehrlich-institut stört sie das gar
nicht doch ist wirklich sehr lasse mich
gerne beraten vom paul-ehrlich-institut
es so deren aufgabe und würde und 22
deren rat auch folgen
nur dass dort im kleinen kreis was
entschieden wird das geht gar nicht wir
haben jetzt die neue rechtslage seit
vier wochen
der bundestag kann alle drei monate
entscheiden ob diese epidemischen lage
vor ort besteht oder nicht besteht
das ist eins erst noch entscheiden
können alle folgerungen sind längst
festgezurrt und durch
verordnungsermächtigung bei herrn spahn
bei der bundesregierung beraten von paul
das ist schon ja muss ja bin ich auch
kein licht mehr meinen wählern die haben
mich doch beauftragt die entscheidung zu
treffen
dazu gedanken zu machen und bin ich an
den massen ausgewählt das finde ich
ziemlich schlimm was da passiert ja
nochmal zu dieser entscheidung zu diesem
impfstoff astrazeneca also dass das das
institut ist das ein ratschlag gibt
unzweifelhaft da sitzen die experten und
es ist über deren expertise zumindest
aus meiner sicht nichts schlechtes zu
sagen aber dass am ende die
beipackzettel dich nicht schreiben quasi
zu gesetzen werden das kann sich sein
oder nein ich glaube im konkreten fall
konnte minister nicht anders entscheiden
seine experten ebenso was raten was wäre
gewesen hätte anders entschieden das
wäre was passiert was ihm vorzuwerfen
ist dass wir das er offenbar sich vorher
auch nicht um gekümmert hat wir haben am
donnerstag zum ersten dänemark andern
jedes jahr jeden tag kann man neues land
dazu diesen stopp verhängt hat der muss
ich mich auch sofort auf der eu eine an
unsere gemeinsame lösung bekümmern
es kann nicht sein die leute wären
völlig verwirrt ist eine land sagt ja
wir stoppen das andere dachten wir
stoppen nicht das kann nur eine eu weit
einheitliche lösung da sind uns entweder
für alle europäer gefährliche gar keinen
wieder hat ein schweres versäumnis
verfahren wie kann es sein noch mal bei
dieser frage bleiben dass solche
institute am ende so weitreichende
entscheidungen treffen dürfen weil die
politik die verantwortung hat outsourced
also als paul ehrlich institut ans lka
an die stiko zum beispiel oder auch an
den deutschen ethiker diese entscheidung
werden outgesourced die sind da besser
aufgehoben
als im bundestag nein weil wir wie
abgeordnete müssen wir ändern uns ja
auch verantworten wenn wir also falsch
entscheiden dann gibt es im september
bundestagswahl dann werden die die
verschiedenen abgewählt das normale
demokratische verfahren nach meiner
kenntnis werden die chefs von bei und ak
ii und so weiter im september stehen die
nicht so war
ja aber sie dürfen uns entscheiden und
sie lassen sich und sie lassen sich
gefallen
auch sie sollen machen wir haben gegen
dieses aus dem ersten gegen alle gesetze
bestimmt maßgeblichen grund nicht nur
allein aber auch mit dem grund dass der
bundestag ausgehebelt wird ich verstehe
ehrlich gesagt die koalitionsfraktionen
noch nicht dass man sagt die pole
position wollen wir nicht beteiligen
dass wir ja noch verstehen aber auch die
koalitionsfraktionen haben wir selber
auch völlig ausgehebelt und die haben
dem zugestimmt ist mir ich nicht gemacht
aber sie stimmen den befund schon zu
also ich glaube dass das nicht weit
hergeholt ist das für den alltag der
deutschen im moment virologen oder
beispielsweise diese impfstoff forscher
affen forscher kann man fast überspitzt
sagen im moment wichtiger sind als die
abgeordnete im bundestag
ja die haben zumindest mehr einfluss
aber ich glaube dass viele menschen sich
auch ihr leben ein bisschen selber
stricken also ich habe heute morgen
apotheke ein bisschen schnupfen und hat
man schnell dass gekaufte 11 euro und
weil der spanier einem kleinen zur
verfügung stellt und ich kann mir das
leisten aber viele menschen sind land
können nicht alle paar tage es euro
ausgeben sondern selbst wenn es nur um
ein paar tage verzögerung am ende für
jahr zehntausende oder hunderttausende
gibt die jetzt in diesen tagen ihre
impftermine hatten wer trägt dann am
ende dafür die verantwortung
das ein großes phänomen wahrscheinlich
gar keine finanzielle gar keine ich bin
ja anwalt und zahnarzt im zivilberuf
sozusagen
da weiß über zehn gewohnt wenn ich was
falsch mache hafte ich dafür und zwar
komplett
ja das kenne ich so über staatliche
institutionen nicht und das ist schon
musste ich mich umgewöhnen ja dass ich
auf einmal das tor ganz andere situation
vorherrsche
dh es werden weitreichende
entscheidungen getroffen für den alltag
von millionen deutschen von allen
deutschen ja eigentlich im moment und es
ist auch völlig klar dass in diesem zuge
fehler passieren können aber wenn fehler
passieren können ist niemand haftbar zu
machen niemand verantwortlich zu machen
doch der steuerzahler der zahlt am ende
der allianzen milliarden wir haben
milliarden hunderte von milliarden aus
da aber viele wissen noch gar nicht
welche summen da im spiel sind und die
wert der steuerzahler abtragen müssen
dass wir hätten mit sicherheit mit
weniger ausgaben auch hinkommen gehen
also sonst konnte die queen nicht sein
das ist klar nicht aber aber das ist
jetzt passiert so viel geld ausgegeben
haben weil es immer auf diesen simplen
lockdown konzentriert haben der extrem
teuer ist und auch wenn man es genau
betrachten nur teilweise was gebracht
hat
ich glaube klügere maßnahmen werden
billiger gewesen und hätten mindestens
genauso viel wahrscheinlich mehr
gebracht